votre voiture c'est terminé maintenant
tonnes de drogue
bien sûr que c'est pas de voiture
mathieu il y a il y en a un qui aime
particulièrement
un objet qui lui appartient vraiment il
est fou de cet objet il est fou
voilà 2 2 ce qui lui permet de venir
tous les jours à des mythes
c'est bien sûr sa voiture à la main sa
venue parce que j'ai deux passions
ouais les montres et les voitures ah oui
et plus que vous adorez votre voiture et
la danse aussi bien ouais ouais je sais
mieux c'est mais ça m'étonne telle
histoire parce qu'aujourd'hui je suis
tombé en panne avec frais et donc voilà
les chais marche plus donc allé chez
enfin je sais monde est allé à chercher
la voiture qu'on est allé chercher à
l'intérieur
roujan nan mais rate un cursus non mais
sérieux c'est une option que j'ai traîné
moi je propose tout de suite 5 sûrs
qu'on fasse qu'on fasse qu'on fasse la
séquence du monster truck
[Applaudissements]
mathieu bien je vais vous poser cinq
questions à remettre la question mais
est ce qu'on peut voir s'il vous plaît
jetons pas avoir une image
faites un plan fait un plan sur l'autre
d'abord aller aller s'y fait imploré
d'uddevalla la même s'il restait là tu
sèches mais là-dessus rester là dessus
s'ils veulent d'abord steven à ce que
vous pouvez montrer ce que vous savez
faire un matthieu delormeau simone
alors ça
ça c'était une voiture qui est à la
casse mathieu je vais tout faire pour
que vous sauviez votre voiture
voici la première question le 4 décembre
2013 dans touche pas à mon poste au smap
la can ont une vraie info sur gérard
louvin est tombé laquelle il a fait de
la coloc avec dette dans les années 60
il a une tante qui s'appelait soeur
gérarld où il a été le premier
producteur de t'choupi en france alors
si vous voyez il a fait de la coloc avec
dave dans les années 60 il a une tante
qui s'appelait soeur gérard où il a été
le premier producteur de t'choupi en
france dell c'est un ami donc je connais
mon arrêt parler c'est la 3 il est déjà
monté dans votre voiture de m oui
absolument
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
attention non c'est la 3 dont il a été
le premier producteur de t'choupi en
france c'était bien sûr sur gérald dont
vous avez perdu
steven antin mais pour bébé
saft
marc occupants
selon stephen c bon ok de footballeur a
provoqué un fou rire sur ce plateau le 7
février 2013 arrêter de montrer sa
voiture ça ne dépriment michel ça pue
nicolas sachy ou pire ses couilles
[Rires]
souviens pas moi alors match aller je
sais plus là vous m'agacer alors
attendez même pu de l'a2 donc nicolas
sachy basse et salle à doha renom alors
ça pue michel sapin mathieu en tout cas
pour vous ça chie pas ça pue steven
avant de remettre mon bébé
[Musique]
oui
là
oui là
alors attention les full options et
légendes sport en plus ce match reste
encore pour quelque chose mais tu dois
aller au bout sans déconner pouvez vous
me dire quel a été le tout premier livre
lu dans voyage au bout de la nuit sur
des 8 voilà c'est mort la poste auch hb
touche tous les deux mathieu géodonnées
trois propositions
oui oui oui et la gomme magique non
le grand meaulnes a peut-être le gustave
flaubert
je sais pas je rigole le grand moule
j'ai fourni on est alain fourny
exactement qui avait entraîné le paris
saint germain ou bien le horla de guy
deux empattements passants et de graines
leader aux passants mathieu là je crois
savoir si vous répondez bien c'est fini
non non et encore de questions ça passe
par contre aux morceaux du peu second
rôle de la voiture le grand bol matthieu
delormeau
si ça n'est pas le grand meaulnes
malheureusement steven va avancer si
c'est le grand moule
le premier livre qui a été lu dans
voyage au bout de la nuit
c'est le horla
voilà la fevad mathieu non mais j'ai des
règles j'ai des huissiers qui sont là
qu'est le csa qui me regarde je peux pas
annoncer quelque chose n'est pas le
faire derrière de vie oui non non non
steven base estivale
calais
alors
attendez voilà mieux
céret sais rien
ça va
c'est beau c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon
aussi bonne calme toi
mathieu n'a pas vrai c'est bon c'est bon
merci jean mathieu mathieu ses tirades
voiture non mais c'est vrai a bien sûr
c'était sa voiture et humaines jean oui
c'est votre voiture mathieu vous
inquiétez pas on va lancer un appel
ensuite à la même c'est même pour cette
voiture qui mathieu voilà quelque chose
à vous montrer c'était votre voiture
bien sûr et votre voiture c'est terminé
maintenant bien sûr que c'est votre
voiture mathieu mais mathieu on n'est
pas des monstres quand même regarder la
transformation d'autres voitures
[Musique]
on
et prend une voiture à la place une
voiture qui était morte et on l'a
reproduit aller à la pêche au thon cette
voiture c'est elle est à l'identique de
votre voiture donc en fait c'est juste
de la tôle
voilà mon manager
[Applaudissements]
l'escale amateurs pour moi c'est un peu
soupçonne vannes c'est parce que
franchement le cuir rouge comme ça sans
aucune pouvait être que la nièvre est
basse et et brandao la reconduite vous
dis à l'identique merci steve
merci bien sûr on n'a pas massacré vie
la voiture de leur donner une autre
voiture c'est une voiture là c'est juste
de la tôle est